the rich get richer offensively in
kansas city they already have the
quarterback as we know they've got the
receivers as we know they've got the
tight end as we know now they've got the
running back just a week ago we were
speculating on the possibility
it wasn't even a week ago it was monday
talking about leonard fournette being a
possible trade candidate for the chiefs
underscoring the fact chris that they
need help at running back they got it
last night at pick 32 your top running
back their top running back the first
running back taken the only running back
taken last night clyde edward solaire of
lsu both of us in our mock drafts had
him at 32 to the chiefs it was one of
those picks that almost made too much
sense to happen and i think they were
exposed to getting leap frogged and have
someone else take clyde edwards hillary
before they could at number 32 but
that's not what happened they have him
and man uh maybe some balance in the
offense maybe another weapon in the
passing game
but uh a good move by the chiefs an
amazing move you know again yeah they
got an area of their football team
that's so great that it's going to have
to change the way teams play them and
they're going to be able to put
tremendous pressure on you you know like
you know again mike it goes back to
defending the whole field certainly
gonna have a better running game with
this guy but when you got kelsey work in
the middle of the field and sammy
watkins and tyree killed deep and now
you got this guy underneath who's gonna
be in the in the conversation for one of
the quickest players in football it's a
phenomenal pick and that's why i love
the chiefs they kind of have like oh
yeah nobody takes running backs in the
first round screw you we know what we
need for our football team we'll do what
we got to do uh great pick here knocked
it out of the park
and remember 498 rushing yards for
damien williams last year for the chiefs
that led the team and he had 90 of them
on one play
this upgrades the running attack
tremendously we'll be back with more
right after this
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports